meet matt walsh he's a douchebag that
works for ben shapiro's company the
daily wire and this is what he tweeted
out this morning we live in a world
where nobody can pay attention to
anything for more than five seconds
there's constant stimulation and
distraction everywhere all the time
there's no such thing as adhd as the
father of a daughter who has adhd i just
want to tell matt walsh
you because
you don't know what it's like first of
all emotional blackmail is not an
argument second point also is that you
actually have no idea about my own life
experience at all you're just assuming
that because i've arrived at different
conclusions from you i must not have had
any of the experiences you have had
because you think
in your
little egotistical pee brain
that anyone who has your life
experiences must arrive at the same
conclusions as you third
if your daughter is upset because her
brain doesn't work like other kids your
solution
is to agree with her
and tell her that her brain is broken
how is that less insulting